[Music]
[Music]
our curators are involved in education
of young architects and these twelve
project be future in the pavilions are
the best example of the architecture
urban design and landscape in Singapore
the shell projects are actually the
stars of this exhibition we have
selected them from many projects that we
listed and they are encompassing what we
are trying to say to respond to the idea
of normal free space so very unique way
of responding to that
in this instance the acrylic structure
is an environment we hope it represents
an environment in Singapore in the
physical sense it is really an acrylic
structure that self-supporting it
transmits light and so in the way that
we simulate the light sequences that
sync with the videos we hope that the
visitors get a sense of this envelope
like a real cloud that envelopes the
business we'll come and see the videos
of the projects
it was challenging to build the lattice
structure or the clouds because we
wanted to be quite ambitious and with
the kind of concept that we had at the
start and atmosphere of light so at the
first thing we had to do was to find an
appropriate material and then a lot of
experimentation went behind how you
actually start to not these acrylic
pieces together
so that you can get a structure that's
both very beautiful and very strong our
vision for design is that design is
going to go beyond just beautiful
objects or beautiful environments but
how design actually can really be able
to kind of shape better way we live and
we live and play in the city I think
there is also the realization that smart
cities cannot be unemotional cannot be
dry cannot be uninteresting so I think
that many of the designers in Singapore
are also conscious of the need to have a
certain quality a certain emotion in the
environment that they are in and I think
that bigness of heart is the single most
important factor for us to grow that
common space and I hope that I hope that
something that we can keep building on
keep enriching and keep little better
for for
[Music]